you're not gonna wanna hear this
but I'm going to share it with you anyway
working hard
particularly if you are a corporate female
just isn't enough to propel you to a leadership role
yes I said what I said
and we're going to deconstruct it today
I am Louise Thompson
I'm a leadership and careers coach with a croaky voice today
thank you Covid
and today I want to talk about why there are more female leaders
and why we traditionally
find it so hard to promote and position our value in the workplace
and it's connected with something that I think
all female professionals need to get better at
it's not their ability to do their job
I have seen so many women that are so highly skilled and technically competent
that just won't get that or can't get that leadership role
and it's not even that they um
haven't particularly been experienced as a leader to date
because knowing that
and knowing what work you have to do in order to become a great leader
is a really green flag in my book
that you are ready to lead
this is what it is instead
and there's a Nick factor
okay I'm not gonna lie
it's about personal brand
self promotion
articulating your value
and making sure that you are clear
and the others are clear on what you uniquely bring to the table
you have got the ick hearing me talk about personal brand
I understand
I used to feel the same way
so earlier on in my corporate career
I was very much of the school that all I need to do is do my job do it well
keep my head down
and that will be seen
that will be recognised
and I'll get promoted right
wrong unfortunately
I have watched less experienced and less expert people
um take roles that I wanted
purely because I wasn't clear enough about what I brought to the table
and why my unique value mattered in that organization
and I'm sure you've heard the stat
it's a common one
that women will typically
only apply for a role if they feel they meet 100% of the criteria
whereas for men
it's more like a 60 to 70%
so there's definitely a confidence gap that we have as women in leadership
that we must overcome and dress
if we to get the roles that we deserve
this is why I always talk about professional positioning
when I coach any leaders
but particularly female leaders
because we need to understand how we can do this
in a way that is aligned with our values
feels authentic
but it's effective enough to get us where we need to be
and to make us visible
I do think this issue of professional visibility and personal brand
is somewhat gendered
particularly in the corporate world and in leadership roles
because again
I have seen so many
and there are so many brilliant men out there
of course I'm not bashing men
there are so many
men that are not as experienced or expert as their female counterparts
getting roles purely because a
they've asked for them
b they've applied for it anyway or c
or a combination of all of these things
they've actually done the work in terms of building relationships
and making sure they are visible
in a way that women more often will not do
because we buy into this myth that just working hard is enough
it's not so self promotion doesn't have to feel icky
it doesn't have to be inauthentic
and you can still stay true to your values
but it is a really essential part of building your leadership brand
let me know your thoughts in the comments
is this a gender issue
or have I got that wrong
um what could women do to make themselves more visible in a credible way
what are your thoughts
let me know and I'll see you with my croaky little voice tomorrow